- Being an adult is hard.
It's so easy to get into a rut
and think about the
inevitability of death.
(laughter)
- What are we thinking?
- Wait, let's just do it.
Okay, we'll do something
totally different.
- We should just start with
something like, fun and light.
High energy.
- Hell yeah!
- [Steven] Action.
- Hey Guys!
- [Steven] Nope.
(Steven laughs)
- Hey, this is Worth
It, where we try to...
- [Steven] This is not Worth It!
(laughs)
I need you to focus.
- Focusing.
- And action.
- This is Go Fun Yourself,
where we take people who are
unsatisfied in their day to day
and set them up with
unconventional hobbies
and we see if it sticks!
- Who are you?
- Oh, I'm Kate, one of your co-hosts,
and that's Steven, your other co-host.
- Nope.
- [Kate] Yes, you are my co-host.
- No.
- You're not a feminist
if you're not my co-host.
- Oh my god.
- A few weeks ago,
we sent out a company-wide email
asking people if they were
unhappy with their day to day
recreational activities.
Turns out, a lot of people are.
Most people just work a lot
and then go home and watch television
and then that's it.
- It's really a lot to
like, do a new thing.
- From those responses, we found Ella.
Now, things about Ella:
She believes that fairies exist.
(Kate giggles)
She does.
She used to be a lifeguard.
She's a very good swimmer
and she doesn't have a
whole lot of hobbies.
So, I'm matching her up with...
Mermaiding!
- Is that a...
Is that a recreation?
- Yeah.
- And then what?
And then what's gonna happen?
- We're gonna see
if it changes her life.
(laughter)
- Alright, that's it!
- This is Go Fun Yourself.
- Yay!
- And today we've got Ella.
- Hello.
- Notoriously unsatisfied.
(laughs)
Oh, this is my co-host, Steven.
- Not co-host.
- He's my co-host.
- No.
- You were looking for a hobby that was...
- I love to be outdoors.
I'd like to be a little creative
and maybe have some fun with it.
Maybe add some more
play back into my life.
I don't know.
- Yes, I believe you said,
"Childlike wonder."
- Childlike wonder, yes.
Being an adult, you get
busy, you get tired.
Also after work I have to
go home and feed myself.
(laughs)
- It just feels like hobbies
aren't worth it after a while.
- Yeah, I'm just tired.
- Obviously, you know of all
like, the conventional hobbies.
Kickball...
That's like the only
hobby that comes to mind.
Kickball and like, stamp collecting.
But there are many other
very, very fun ones.
- Are there?
I'm honestly a little nervous.
- It's gonna be pretty embarrassing.
It involves being completely naked.
(laughs)
She's not listening.
(laughter)
- I cannot wait!
(tropical island music)
- Okay, we're gonna reveal it now.
You're gonna freakin' lose your mind!
- Oh (bleep).
- Three, two, one!
Ba-boom!
- Ah!
Hi.
Oh my god.
- Welcome to your new hobby!
- My hobby is becoming a mermaid?
- Yeah.
You're gonna get a fin and everything.
- Holy (bleep).
They're not real mermaids right?
- No, they're not real mermaids.
- My mermaid name is Caribbean Peal
and I've been a mermaid for seven years.
- My name is Mermaid Abby
and I've been a mermaid
since I was two years old.
(shine sound effect)
- I kinda wanna cry because I'm scared.
- You're scared?
Why are you scared?
- Here's the thing.
I am a little afraid of people
that dress up like characters.
Anyone's who's like
dressing up in an outfit
and like being a character,
because I know that it's not really them
and I'm like a little weirded out.
(laughter)
- I may have fucked up.
- I respect them.
I respect what they do.
They're very talented.
- Here's the thing, I love mermaids...
- And you used to swim,
and you're about to put on a fin
and swim with professional mermaids!
- Even though I'm a little bit nervous,
I'm gonna try to keep an open mind
and just try to have fun with it.
(tropical island music)
- Hi, I'm Ella.
- My name is Merman Jax.
I am the founder and a
performer for a company called,
Dark Tide Productions.
- Okay.
- And today,
we're gonna teach you how to be a mermaid.
- How did you get into this?
- It's one of those things.
I grew up as a competitive swimmer.
- Okay.
- And I've worked
in the entertainment industry
and I kinda just fell into it,
but it's actually really
good for your body,
and it's nice on the joints,
it's good exercise and it's fun!
- So not only am I learning a hobby,
but a potential new career.
- Potentially.
Depending, that's up to you buddy.
Your name is Merman Jax, yes?
- Yes.
- So, is that your character?
- That is the character name, yes.
- Okay, Ella will be
coming up with a character.
- Absolutely.
- [Kate] Yes.
- Opposed to a persona,
it'll be a mersona.
(gasps)
- She'll be coming up with a mersona!
- So here are some tops,
accessories, things to think about.
And your beautiful tail
that you get to use today.
- [Ella] I love it!
- It's from Swimtails,
they provided this for you.
This is where we can start thinking about
if any of these inspire you.
- I can see like, why
she'd pick this for me,
because I do like mermaids
and I talk about them a lot.
- Are you gonna be maybe more mysterious,
maybe more sexy or maybe if your shy,
you're more outgoing or friendly.
- Are there evil mermaids?
- Absolutely.
That can be the thing, you
can look innocent and sweet,
but you can actually be a siren.
Maybe you want to drown people.
- Yeah, I think that's what I want to do.
- Yeah, you wanna drown people?
- I wanna lure them in and
than I wanna drown them.
- Oh no!
- These are really beautiful
but let's be honest,
I don't have the goods
to fill up those tops.
I'm a sporty mermaid.
- [Merman Jax] You're athletic.
- I'm an athletic,
evil mermaid.
- There you go.
There it is.
- Wow, it all happened so fast.
The second you put the crown on.
- And the last and final step
is gonna be picking what you
want your mermaid name to be.
- I don't know.
I think I need to get into my outfit.
I need to practice some moves
and I think the name
will become clear then.
- The first thing I'm gonna have you do
is just go ahead and lean back.
- Okay.
- Arch your back, put your shoulders back
and just sunbathe.
- Okay.
- And give us a smile.
It can be like an evil smile, right?
I'm gonna have you go to your tummy.
- Oh gosh.
(Kate laughs)
- I didn't think this would be work.
- Give me your hands like this.
- Okay.
- And then put your fin up in the air.
- Yes, girl!
- Hey!
Oh I'm trying to entice people over to me.
- Just stopping by to
see how you're feeling.
- I'm like, scared that I'm
not gonna be able to do this.
- I got your back, merbabe.
- Merbabe!
(laughs)
Aw thank you.
- You're gonna be fintastic,
I don't know what she's talking about.
- Fintastic!
- The puns coming out
of this one are wild.
How do I get into this?
- We're going to roll down
the body of your tail.
- Okay.
So that you can put your
foot into your fluke.
(screams)
- I just got really excited!
Okay, yeah.
- [Kate] You're feeling the fin.
- I'm feelin' the fin.
- Imagine that.
- (island whistle music)
- So, you know how to swim.
- Yes, I did life guarding
and like, swim team.
- Oh, that's really good!
- I'm really comfortable in the water.
- Okay, the Dolphin
Stroke, or the S-Curve,
is just the butterfly.
- [Ella] I never really did that one.
- Okay, it's the...
- It's a lot of hip action.
- Up and down, yes.
- Worse comes to worst, I can just float.
- You can just float beautifully.
- Yeah.
- That's perfect.
- [Kate] Slip on in.
(upbeat funky music)
- [Kate] Ooh!
- And I think one of the
fun tricks we'll teach you
is the "Tail Slap."
Pretty simple, get a little speed.
See, just flip up like that.
- That?
Okay.
- You can go really bit,
you can go really small.
- Being a mermaid is a lot of work.
(sighs)
- If you're really ready to go,
we're gonna have you try a
"corkscrew" or a "barrel roll."
- Oh!
- Try that.
- She's doing great.
I don't think she even needs us, really.
(laughs)
- We just had to bring
in the tail, that was it.
- [Merman Jax] She's a natural.
(upbeat funky music)
- [Narrator] Ladies and
gentlemen, introducing,
Sapphire the Siren!
- Oh my god!
- Hello, my name is Sapphire the Siren.
- Kate texted me and said,
"Do you wanna see Ella be a mermaid?"
And I didn't know that she meant for real.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh yeah this is real.
- This is a mer...
Mer-velous day.
(laughter)
- It is cool, but it's not freakin' all.
We got some tricks to show you.
- Tricks, like you're a trained dolphin?
- Liked a trained gosh dang mermaid!
(water splash)
- [Merman Jax] This is the
moment we've been waiting for.
(applause and cheering)
- Oh, there she goes!
- [Male Friend] Graceful, like a mermaid.
- Oh wow!
(friends cheering)
- That was...
I was convinced.
- She legit looks like a mermaid.
- This is the weirdest moment
of our friendship for sure.
You're welcome Quinta.
- Hi, how's it going?
- Come sit by me so you can use the...
(laughs)
- [Quinta] Didn't we
always see her as this?
- [Female Friend] Yeah, Ella is a mermaid.
I always thought of her as
like a fair or a mermaid.
- [Quinta] True, true.
It really does feel like
I'm at the aquarium.
(laughter)
- Oh splash zone!
We're in the splash zone!
(applause and cheering)
- [Male Friend] Yay Ella!
- [Female Friend] Sapphire!
- So, you learned a new hobby today.
We had some ups and downs.
- I did.
I think I was having like, a little ego,
and I was nervous of like, looking dumb.
But once I got in that tail.
- That was a game-changer.
The second you pulled up that tail,
you literally got into character.
- I'm gonna be honest, it
was really, really fun.
I had a blast.
- [Kate] You looked like
you were having so much fun.
- And I have been really
stressed out lately,
working so much so, you
know what, thank you Kate.
This was really, really good.
- Oh my god!
So, would you say it was, Worth It?
I'm just kidding.
(laughter)
- This was definitely a unique hobby.
But this really reminded me
to have a little bit more fun
and take stuff less seriously.
I can't believe it took you
and these three mermaids
to remind me of that.
- Wow.
Change is possible, kids.
- [Ella] I know this sounds silly,
but I did have a great time.
- What a day, what a whirlwind.
- Fun.
- It was fun and she ended
up having fun and liking it.
- [Steven] So what have
we learned from this?
- [Kate] I learned that I
should put on more sunscreen.
- Hey Unsolved is on a new channel,
and now your part.
- [Together] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.